hey everyone this is kevin from
thechesswebsite.com and today we are in
game number five of the 2021 world chess
championships being held in dubai this
is a best of 14 series first player to
seven and a half points will be the
world champion you get a full point for
a win you get half a point for a draw
competitors obviously the champion
magnus carlsen defending his title
against dion nepo he won the candidates
tournament earlier in the year first
four games have all been draws yon nepo
has the white pieces today trying to
break
through remember
before this these players had played 13
times and yonepo had a better classical
rating against magnus carlsen so he
definitely has the upper hand
historically we'll see if that
translates into some victories here in
the world championship so he starts out
with pawn to e4 as he has done in the
first
two games game one and three that he
played the white pieces magnus defends
the same way e5 knight to f3 knight c6
bishop to b5 so getting into the ryde
lopez that we have seen before
a6 bishop comes back to a4 and so
definitely looks like we are seeing
similar moves to game one and game three
then we'll just have to figure out if
they decide to
change things up at some point tonight
to f6 castle on the king side
bishop to e7 rook here to e1 bishop to
b5 bishop comes back here to b3 and then
castle on the king side so the first
seven moves have all been identical to
game one and game three this is the anti
uh marshall setting up for you know
typically you have your your martial
attack with pawn to c3 but so far janepo
game one he opted for h3
and in game three he opted for a4 you
know both of those are the anti-martial
really getting away from the c3 and then
black pushing forward with d5 so it does
not seem like
jan's really looking to play that he
goes back to the well with a4 so exactly
what he played in game number three
he plays here on h4 and this is where
some of the psychology in chess comes in
especially at the highest level
i think more than any other player
manage carlson really respects yonepo
you can tell this if you watch any of
the interviews um if you just listen to
how magnus carlsen talks about his
opponent knowing their history they've
had when they played classical chess
nepo is a smart guy and magnus knows
that there's a reason that he's playing
a4 here he just played that in
game number three you know you look at
game number one it was a draw and so
game number three he changes it up
instead of playing h3 he now plays a4
he's going back to the same move that he
played before so managed crossing being
smart guys like why would he do that
unless he thinks he can get an advantage
at some point if i keep repeating the
same move so magnus carlson in game
number three played bishop here to b7
madness carlson says
okay if you're gonna do this
you have you have something going on
here and i don't want to figure out when
and where that's going to take place so
i'm not going to play any more moves
that are the same i am now going to be
the one to change it up so that's
exactly what he does and he plays rook
to b8
now we see an exchange here on b5 the
pawns come off the board now pawn to h3
so similar setup on the king side that
we have seen in the previous games here
pawn to d6 pawn here to c3 which
typically means especially in this
opening pushing forward to d4 is the
play especially after you see d6 you're
not as worried about
black pushing immediately here to d5 so
after c3 uh fully expected something
like bishop here to
d7 and then
d4
maybe we start to see some
uh pieces come off the board rook to a8
is pretty common rook takes queen takes
here maybe knight to a3 attacking this
pawn here on b5 that can't easily be
protected by the pawn on c7
but we see something that i think's uh
fairly interesting for madness cross and
he plays pawn to b4 which wait we can
still see white continue just push
forward here with d4 and then maybe
there's an exchange right here
after the pawn takes pawn takes right
here you can also take it with his
knight but then you have an isolated
pawn here on the c file so i think many
times white might just take with their
pawn right here maybe pawn d5 and then
pawn e5 but we see after the move
b4 we see d3 which i think is also
pretty interesting we're definitely not
in the book lines this is this is new
theory we're seeing right here from the
player so a lot of prep seems to have
gone in to this specific position pawn
takes on c3
pawn takes so neither side has the
isolated pawns that we just looked at
maybe part of the reason they wanted to
play that knight to d2 here pawn takes
pawn takes here on e4 now they do have
the isolated pawns here on the c file
but you can also see it's fairly
mirrored for both sides as far as both
material and setup
the isolated pawns both on the c file
both sides have all of their material
outside of their pawns
and both of the uh pawns here on the e
file are locked on the e4 and e5 square
so queen to c2 doing double duty here
protecting this pawn on e4 also
protecting the pawn here on
c3 pawn to h6 just protecting the square
here on g5 similar to how this pawn on
h3 is defending this square here on
g4 from the knight coming in knight
comes back here to f1 preparing to come
over here to g3 and we see similar thing
for magnus carlsen knight back here to
e7 prepare to come to
g6 that's exactly what we see g3 and
then g6 bishop here to e3 queen over
here to e8 rook 2 d1 getting into an
open file you always want to put your
rooks on open files where there's no
pawns it can freely control the entire
file or semi-open if there's just one
pawn on the file that's also going to be
good for
the rook bishop here to e6 we do see
jan's not ready to trade off quite yet
plays bishop here to a4 attacking the
queen bishop comes back d7
knight to d2 just rearranging moved it
over to the king side uh but didn't
realize hey there's just not going to be
too much with both of my knights here so
the knight on f3 it's been hanging out
there since the beginning now comes back
to d2 bishop takes so we do see an
exchange magnus carlson typically likes
to have his bishop pair so the fact that
he's the one to initiate the trade
makes it seem like he's not going to be
the aggressor in this game for black
queen takes rick takes here on a4 so the
queens come off the board now the kings
can start to get involved into the
action at some point rook over here to
a8
we do see the exchange of pieces
going down and you can start to see
it's going to be difficult for either
side to really get an advantage mostly
because of how symmetrical the board is
and they have the exact amount of
material so really hard to see any side
unless someone messes up which so far
we've played four and a half games now
this game's not over but there really
hasn't been any mistake even a slight
mistake which is crazy to think about
these players are playing you know hours
and hours a day and just not making any
mistakes it's the highest level of
classical chess uh for sure
rook here 2 a6 was kind of hoping in
this spot that we see something like
knight to f6 attacking this bishop right
here this is a great outpost for this
knight
i think it's really the only thing that
we can look at and say how can white be
aggressive and try to go for a win here
you know rook to a6 attacking the bishop
but the bishop's not going it's not
going to trade off his rook for the
bishop so i thought this was
you know
incrementally improving his position but
not really changing anything magnus
carlsen is not going to lose his
position after rook to a6
knight to f5 though i think it's
interesting that's not what he plays in
the game
knight to e8 magnus carlsen plays king
over here to f1 starting to get the king
ball into the game and then knight to f8
so this really signifies to me madness
carlson is all in on the defense train
not necessarily trying to rearrange his
material i mean this knight here on e8
it's not coming here to d6 it's not
coming here to c7 yes it can defend this
this bishop but that's about it doesn't
really need to do anything else with it
so he's in full defense mode yeah i'm
trying to hold on to
this bishop and i can rearrange
elsewhere but other than that it's not
going to come to g7 so it just comes
back to the same square that it was so
full defense mode for madness carlson no
longer trying to win so this is where i
really think yan should try
to be fairly aggressive starts out with
knight to f5 so i think that is the best
move for him right here to e6 that
appeared to c4 attacking this bishop
rook to d8 holding down the bishop pawn
to f3 just solidifying the pawn chain
right here pawn f6 same thing starts
pushing forward here with g4
king f7
pawn two h4 just pushing here on the
king side bishop comes back to f8
remember uh in a full defensive mode
there's not too many moves that magnus
carlsen has his pieces are pretty much
blocked off king here to e2
knight here to d6 knight takes bishop
takes here uh and then pawn to h5 you
start to look at and
it's very difficult to figure out how
you can actually break through because
both sides are so symmetrical you can't
really you know sometimes you'll have
the pawn advantage on one side of the
board and so you kind of rotate all your
pieces to that side and see if you can
get advantage in this case you don't
really see that coming into play so
bishop comes back to f8
you kind of see this song and dance just
moving back and forth between the
seventh and eighth rank here from manish
carlson rook over here to d5 rook to a8
work down here to d1 and magnus carlson
says you know what uh yeah i have a
pretty fine position right here so i'm
just going to attack your king here uh
kind of be
uh annoying but other than that there's
not too much that he's trying to do he
doesn't have any other material
that can really help him the knight just
can't come down because this bishop is
defending both of those squares so the
rook's in it by himself
but it's going to be pretty easy to to
block and that's exactly what we see
nepo play rook 2 d2 blocking that
and then we see
just a
continued repetition and so it is a
drawn game after 42 moves so for anyone
that projected that there would be a
draw i don't know how you could have
ever projected that but game number five
is a draw five draws in a row i know
many of you are looking for
a win but
i think in some ways these players are
trying uh i'm not necessarily sure that
the anti-martial lines that yonepo is
playing are going to do the trick
against madness crosston every time he
plays it madness carlson is getting
better and better at defending it and
madness carlson is one of those players
that if he understands an opening and
what you're trying to do it's going to
be very hard for him to break through so
i think he's gonna have to try something
pretty darn creative uh to break through
against magnus carlsen he's done it in
the past he has not used these lines so
curiously if he if he changes that up
but thank you guys so much for watching
uh the videos even in the draws
hopefully they are still entertaining
and you're learning something it is the
highest level of chess so there's not
going to be a ton of mistakes it just is
what it is but it's still a fun series
and i'm glad you guys are joining in
with me so thanks again i'll see you
guys in the next video remember there is
a break tomorrow they have two days on
so they had game four and five there
will be a rest day tomorrow but we will
be back in two days for game number six
hoping for magnus crossing the white
pieces does something creative see you
guys